étude selon qui le profit à
atteint des sommets.
C'est le cas pour les
entreprises de l'alimentation.
Charles Dumoulin.
- L'institut de la recherche
socio-économique offre d'autres
pistes.
Selon son nouveau rapport, les
profits des entreprises
canadiennes n'ont jamais été
aussi élevés en plus de 20 ans.
Leurs bénéfices auraient
augmenté de plus de 10 % au
cours des quatre derniers
trimestres.
- Une entreprise...
manifestement il y a eu certains
secteurs où les prix ont
augmenté encore plus que
justifieion.
- Selon les chercheurs, les
commerçants n'auraient tiré
avantage.
Leur marge de bénéfices a plus
que doublé en moins d'un an.
En grossissant plus de 3,6
milliards de dollars en
bénéfices supplémentaires.
Les consommateurs perd patience.
- C'était cinq dollars une
mangue.
Charlotte on exagère, sur le
prix du lait, le beurre c'est l.
- Je suis rendu où je mange de
la salade parce que ce n'est
plus achetable, la viande.
- Le rapport de l'iris fait
fausse route selon certains.
- Ce n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour les PME.
Les propriétaires de PME sont
aussi des consommateurs, il voit
l'inflation comme tout le monde.
L'inflation s'est définitivement
pas une bonne nouvelle pour les
entrepreneurs.
- En plus des haus
salaires, les entreprises
demandent au gouvernement
d'accroître...  pour limiter
l'exagération de lion
des prix.
On propose d'imposer des tarifs
d'électricité et de services de
garde etports enports enports en
commun.
Des solutions peu efficaces
selon un économiste.
- L'instrument le plus important
c'est le